all right
let's do something a little bit less
serious here is a controversy with
slightly smaller Stakes
so this video has gone viral it's a
video of a uh Karen
and that's how it's labeled anyway
that's what that's what and this is one
of the most popular genres of videos on
social media are this supposed you know
quote-unquote Karen videos and uh it's a
video of a Karen a white woman being put
in her place allegedly uh getting her
come up comeuppance
and for those not watching the the video
podcast this is what the video shows it
shows this woman this alleged Karen in a
confrontation with a neighbor in her
apartment complex through through and
this conversation is happening through
the ring doorbell camera
he never comes to the door to actually
talk to her but he confronts her because
she apparently was messing with his
welcome mat he had a welcome man outside
of his door but it had a profanity on it
apparently had the f word from what I
read it was like it said f off I think
in big block letters and she didn't like
that so she flipped the the mat over so
that the words weren't seen he was very
upset about that and it led to uh this
exchange which will watch a quick piece
of that
excuse me ma'am
can you pick up can you pick my Rook
back up because I saw that you flipped
it over early it was not bothering you
or anyone
sir I don't think it's appropriate it
does not matter leave here this is a
it does not matter what you deem
appropriate nobody else has said
anything about it does not give you the
right to touch anything on my damn porch
you go up there and tell your goddamn
husband to come see me when I come home
I'll be home at 5 30 make sure you out
make sure you're there ma'am so you come
down and talk
take your shake ass upstairs
do you want to talk to me again
foreign
look I'm not trying to be ugly and I'm
not trying to cause any scene with you
whatsoever we live in a family
environment here I have children here
too to me having the F word or near
doormat is not
respectful of anyone that lives here and
it's not respectful of you to touch my
property it's not bothering anybody and
I have my neighbors across the hall for
your mat I will pay you for your mat but
get that out of here I don't know what
made you change it to something so ugly
as that but I'm I'm not gonna no no
okay that's good that's fine and then
then he starts insulting her all right
so first of all this woman has not done
or said anything that deserves to be
labeled Karen
uh and that's why you know I as you know
I just I hate that term because Karen is
it is simply a racist smear against
white women that that is what it is and
so if you're one of those people that
goes around using the term
um
just stop using it like that that is
that is the the etymology of this slur
it's where it comes from it's originally
a slur by black people on social media
to uh smear and make fun of white women
that's where it comes from that's what
it is it is a racial slur and it is and
now it's at a point where it's just like
if you're a white woman between the ages
of 40 and 80 then you automatically you
automatically fall into that guy and
anything you do if you get if you God
forbid get upset about something you're
automatically a Karen and it's I I you
know I I don't my mom is in that
category of being a woman between those
ages a white woman and so I'm actually
not okay with with hating an entire
demographic of people like this and I I
don't quite understand why
people just accept that
um and because we all know that if we
started referring to black women with a
stereotypical name
okay if I saw a video of an angry black
woman
and said like
oh this Shaniqua over there if I said
that it would be judged horrifically
racist
and yet this is okay and I I'm just done
with that we got to be done with that
this this this double standard that we
allow to exist
and you got a bunch of hen packed
cowardly white people who go along with
it and so it's not the same thing at all
yes it is it's a slur against you have
some damn self-respect
now second
any reasonable person knows that you are
wrong if you go out of your way to put a
sign with huge profanities on it uh
right where kids are walking around uh
that there's there's no good reason to
do that there's no justification for it
but some people are saying well she
should have handled it differently she
should have gone to the property manager
or whatever
fine but I wouldn't if that was me I
would have picked up I would have picked
the the the mat up now I would have
thrown it away is what I would have done
even if it's not my property you can say
that's not your property I don't care
that it's not my property because you
know why
I'm F I'm fine with people taking
matters into their own hands like this
because people are sick of this they're
just sick of it
this is a this is this is a good warning
for all of uh anyone out there who
thinks it's fun to be just an obnoxious
jerk with no class and no dignity and no
decorum and no sense of of basic
responsibility you know to to for the
fact that you're an adult in society and
there are kids around everything is
vulgar now right everything it's just
everything's vulgar and ugly and and our
kids are exposed to it and it's
everywhere and I can see where this
woman's coming from it's just you see
this thing this stuff everywhere and now
this guy this freaking guy has decided
to put it on his welcome mat why
can we get a break from it like can I
walk down the hallway in the apartment
complex without seeing this stuff
people are tired of it
they're sick of it
and they should be
okay and they're not gonna go through
the proper channels you go through the
proper channels and nothing happens
you know that the the the guy there in
in the apartment clearly it's a black
guy you know uh
go go to the if she's a white woman so
it's all automatically there's the
racial Dynamic and she goes and she goes
to property manager and then and then
you know who knows the next thing I'm
gonna tell it's like well your your
concerns don't matter because now
there's the the uh the competition of of
identity demographics here and
you know so people don't want to go
through the proper channels anymore
taking matters into their own hands
I saw a video this is it's not a recent
video I think it was from a few months
ago the guy uh
on a plane
with a big with a sweater that said uh f
f Biden on it but actually said the word
you know the f word in big block letters
and he was and they were in the video
they're trying to throw him off the
plane
um because they've got policy against
having it's not about you know it's not
about defending Biden you know I'm not
going to do that but it's just it's the
vulgarity it's the profanity and they've
got a policies this is their private
property you can't walk in here with
with huge uh profanities on your
clothing
but even that there's like people on the
internet are defending it moves Free
Speech rights oh shut up
how about just a basic level of decency
is is all is being asked for
and I'm telling you people are sick of
it
you walk around like that you know
you're you're lucky if you just get
thrown out eventually people are gonna
you're gonna you're gonna punch right in
the face of what's gonna happen because
people are so tired of it especially
parents
Fed Up
to get this ugliness and this vulgarity
everywhere all the time and we are sick
of it
and these people that are just they they
feel like they're they're not
responsible to anyone they do whatever I
want
so
she's totally in the right here that'll
do it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you well no
talk to you next year
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]